le festival de cannes ce sont des gros
films en compétition mais aussi des plus
petits qui des courts métrages ici au
palais du festival un coin est
spécialement dédié aux courts métrages
on va à la rencontre de benjamin ifra il
est auteur et scénariste du film sweet
dreams au passage
du coup à benjamin td réalisateur du
court-métrage sweet dreams donc on parle
de rêve et été ratée à cannes
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ça représente
pour quoi pour toi d'être ici au
festival c'est une occasion de fou parce
que quatre
gros festivals français en tous cas
surtout curieux de voir ce que ça donne
peu à cannes les marcheurs au jeu les
célébrités les costume de pingouin tout
ça ça m'intrigue qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que tu t'es dit avant d'arriver à cannes
qualité da vision du festival je me suis
dit
est-ce que ça va être très guindé est-ce
que ça va être que d
les célébrités des soirées où tu rentres
pas parce que de toute façon c'est très
près high level est en fait de ce que je
vois c'est aussi à beaucoup de gens de
professionnels de jeune acteur
réalisateur producteur émergents qui qui
viennent et c'est le cas de benjamin
avec le film sweet dreams en gros il ya
le service après-vente des rêves dans
lequel tout le monde travaille avec
beaucoup d'application
sauf une meuf qui s'appelle j'ai dit on
et qui a beaucoup la flemme de
travailler sous la
[Musique]
halle aux capus cher pour vous messieurs
du coup le moment où tomas qui est un
client mécontent de ses rêves parce que
ça se termine jamais comme on veut et
sait il appelle il va se heurter à la
flemme de judith et la communication va
venir se passait bien que des bugs avec
votre service là j'étais en train de
rêver que je dînais avec scarlett
johansson au moment où je l'embrassé je
m'aperçois que c'est plus scarlett
johansson c'est ma mère comment comment
une idée de ce film prévenu toi c'est un
film que j'ai fait pour le nikon
festival cette année le thème c'était le
rêve je suis toujours intéressé par les
périphs technologique et
j'aime bien faire ce qu'on appelle des
fins ce qu'on appelle je sais pas ça
s'appelle encore comme ça mais des
comédies dystopique benjamin des projets
plein la tête il travaille notamment sur
une série d'animations mais aussi sur
une série